[Applauso]
[Musica]
sarà ma sera allora io oggi mi occupo di
ira strumento tecnologico di supporto a
progetti di ricerca e sviluppo ma per un
lungo perché della mia vita ho fatto
altro fatto ricercatore e altre cose mi
sono occupato di questo
questa è utopia mi hanno parlato anche
francesco fa
tommaso moro e la città del sole di
qualche decennio posteriore molto simile
come vedete questo è piuttosto
differente quest'oggi veramente più che
un'utopia
la definiremmo una distopia no sono di
france 3 di fuochi e l'ho scelto questa
fra le decine di possibilità che mi
offriva l'ottocento perché hai spiegato
alcune esperienze urbanistiche
anche qui vicino per esempio il
quartiere paolo sesto di tanto perché
mentre stava voto pia ed antropologo me
interessate il rapporto fra l'uomo e il
circostante dei gruppi umani è il luogo
che abitavano che abitano le comunità
insomma questo è il nocciolo che
costituisce una comunità è però mi
interessava anche visto che cominciò a
occuparmi di questi è legata cambiamenti
climatici mentre stava come mutano i
rapporti fra le comunità umane i luoghi
al mutare delle disponibilità del delle
risorse di fronte alla scarsità delle
risorse
in effetti questa e una delle opzioni
che moltissime opzioni da scegliere
questo e singapore che fluttua sugli
oceani colmi e è chiaro che la comunità
che vive lì dentro che in quell'isola
sospesa deve confrontarsi con diversi
tipi di scarsità in primo luogo
chiaramente come scarsità di creazioni
perché è isolata nel vero senso della
parola e quindi oltre a essere
autosufficiente deve essere certamente
comunità autonoma quando parliamo di
utopia oltre che insomma of fashion
parliamo certamente pensiamo tutti
quanti a a questo alla luna questo è
astolfo ovviamente qualcuno ha
riconosciuto maggior parte dai
conosciuto ma bellissimi prestazione
astolfo va a cercare il senno perduto di
orlando sulla sulla luna perché perché
realtà dalla notte dei tempi è il caso
di dire questo tale con l'argento
sospesi in cielo
chiaramente ci ha invitati a ragionare
su cosa fosse realmente su cosa
contenesse di cosa fosse fatto cosa
ospitasse emerito di catania secondo
luciano è stato il primo astronauta
il primo a fare un viaggio sulla luna ci
trovate le creature mostruose che
guerreggiavano perché in fondo tutto il
mondo è paese anche i satelliti e il
rimun cause non so se insomma si
arrampica sulla pianta per arrivare
sulla luna
questo è molto famosa mela
viaggio nella luna maria senso piuttosto
letterale questa invece è la volo 11
adesso non so quanto bene si lega la
frase di buzzati è un pensiero che
insomma ha accomunato molti
intellettuali nei giorni precedenti al
maggio del quale ricorre il
cinquantenario agli intellettuali e
soprattutto ai poeti non sfuggiva
certamente il fatto che si stessero fa
nando in qualche maniera il sancta
santorum dell'immaginario del mistero
strano per come dick avere contezza
inopinabili né probabile di cosa ci
fosse veramente sulla superficie della
luna
chiaramente la bandiera mericano il
primo piano perché l'allunaggio avviene
in piena guerra fredda
in effetti se avete andata a finire
cosa ci dobbiamo trovate in effetti
sulla luna questa è una lista parziale
la nasa sostiene che per ogni dollaro
investito nella l'omaggio ci sono 67 di
fallout tecnologico ora non sono
francamente in grado di determinare
quanto si attendibili questa stima so
che in effetti cioè il 1976 e il 2018
soltanto la nasa ha computato oltre
duemila fra prodotti e servizi concepiti
per lo spazio e che poi sono atterrati
sul mercato terrestre questo è
probabilmente diciamo l'accezione più
nota di laboratorio spaziale ci sono
altri due però che vorrei
insomma sollevare con voi stasera 1 è
questa qui il laboratorio spaziale e è
piuttosto che tra le vediamo una
ricercatrice che sta osservando delle
violette abbiamo evidenze scientifiche
ormai secche statistiche sull'impatto
positivo che la ricerca spaziale in
particolar modo il testing microgravità
a su la ricerca medica e parlo di
tematiche insomma che ci coinvolgono
direttamente come la ricerca sul cancro
o le cellule staminali
fra le moltissime pubblicazioni
disponibili in rete ho estratto questa
slide che evidenzia come
il test in microgravità che al centro
sia in effetti una soluzione molto
funzionale per questo tipo di ricerca
qui c'è una rappresentazione non so
quanto evidente
diciamo delle modalità con le quali
possiamo fare ricerca in microgravità
ci sono delle modalità che prevedono che
possa essere fatta sulla terra le
cosiddette choke tower sono dei silos
all'interno dei quali vengono verificate
delle condizioni particolari gli oggetti
vengono fatti cadere questo stato di
caduta libera continua è la microgravità
poi ci sono i voli parabolici ci sono
negozi sonda c'è la stazione spaziale
internazionale chiaramente è un domani
ci saranno le basi con ali e le basi
marziane che ci consentiranno ai testi
che microgravità non per secondi come
accade nella tower over minuti come
ragazzi sonda ma per settimane mesi anni
ora l'aspetto interessante è che sebbene
forse la ricerca medica sia quella più
nota la microgravità ha degli effetti
molto positivi anche su altri su altre
attività di ricerca e in effetti
microgravità può sopportare la ricerca
il testing in tutte le cosiddette
industry dall'agricoltura ai processi di
sfiga che più più inconsueti la
microgravità può sviluppare processi
migliori può aiutarci a sviluppare nuovi
prodotti può farci risparmiare risorse
per questo motivo sono nate delle
aziende che cercano di occupare questo
segmento
questo caso riutilizzabile vuol dire che
va a una certa quota e rilasciano da del
suo payload il suo carico o lo riporta
giu e può essere lanciato nuovamente nel
volgere di qualche ora e produce un
azienda texana che si chiama exor e
questo invece è un progetto di
laboratorio spaziale è una teca cambiare
nelle vie sospesa no è una gigantesca
insediamento sospeso nel vuoto siderale
nel quale si possono fare
sperimentazioni
cosa manca per realizzare pienamente
questo segmento
manca un po di ricerca non da parte loro
che l'hanno insomma ne hanno fatto
abbondantemente da parte nostra vi si
tratta di stabilire chiaramente i
rapporti costi benefici
sarà insomma dell'investimento in questo
tipo di di testing e gli altri ma questo
è la seconda delle accezioni che volevo
sviluppare con voi stasera e non la
principale mio avviso progetto anni
scarsità scarsità di cosa in effetti
questa bellissima immagine questa hubble
sembra tutt'altro che scarsa no sembra
molto piena molto piena di luci molto
piena di colori effetti nello spazio
cioè abbondanza di tante cose per quanto
magari non nello stato che noi
chiederemo quindi magari non
immediatamente disponibili per noi
per noi invece per quelle che servono a
noi cioè certamente una scarsità di
ossigeno
c'è una scarsità di acqua anche se
sappiamo che in campo ci sono la
scarsità di risorse per come lo
intendiamo noi dover buchi metall
immediatamente disponibili
ma in realtà la scarsità principale
nello spazio è questa l'assortimento di
competenze e oggi sostanzialmente
impossibile molto costoso per importare
molte persone nello spazio ma immaginate
facilmente che insomma anche la
cassazione spaziali siano richieste
molte tipologie di competenze un
assortimento ampio
in effetti sia qui oggi
questa è la sua immagine stazione
spaziale sia qui domani
questo è un ipotesi di insegnamento
kunar e sarà molto complicato portare
tutte le competenze richieste
e allora cosa bisogna fare è l'unica
soluzione è sostituire queste competenze
con altro e questo alto probabilmente
non possono essere le tecnologie e
questa bocca e dire è una grandissima
opportunità è un eccezionale sempre
stato eccezionale motore
di evoluzione di sviluppo per l'umanità
non ha il tempo di farvi alti esempi
però in buona sostanza noi oggi ci
concentriamo in particolar modo su le
prime due fasi quella rosa salmone della
dell'evoluzione di un innovazione sono
le fasi titanic e premete che noi siamo
a immaginare gli innovatori un po come
dei prometeo no ma in realtà l'impatto
vero sulla collettività all'impatto che
la società arriva le fasi blu quando
l'innovazione si diffonde quando appunto
diventa condivisa e questa cosa vale per
le tecnologie ma vale anche per le
competenze ea maggior ragione se queste
competenze servono in qualche maniera
utilizzare queste tecnologie per
chiarire il concetto
ho scelto un esempio che e speriamo
quotidianamente che sono le competenze
chiamiamo che digitali il computer e
tutti coloro che sono in questa sala che
siano più grande di me o più giovani di
me ricorderanno che sapranno che
all'inizio della storia computer degli
strumenti giganteschi che andavano
informati con delle schede traforate
erano tecnologie molto rare e
richiedevano per essere usata delle
competenze molto rare a un certo punto
c'è stato chiaramente una diffusione
maggiore negli anni 80 mi ricordo che
mio padre e mio zio per farmi giocare
con i personal computer
dobbiamo comunque scrive l'ex thing di
testo piuttosto lunghe la tecnologia era
più diffusa la competenza era più
diffusa ma rimanevano tuttavia tutto
diciamo che largamente condivisi
condivisa e poi sono arrivati
chiaramente dei sistemi operativi che
hanno reso fruibile la tecnologia da
tutti ecco fruibile per me significa che
questa tecnologia è utilizzabile ma che
chi lo utilizza non ne comprende a fondo
la struttura la logica e quindi non è in
grado di intervenire su quella
tecnologia non è in grado di modificarla
il massimo della fruibilità chiaramente
sono le app con una mia nipote a due
anni ha ordinato una pizza a domicilio e
con una neonata che ne ha 70 e non ha
mai utilizzato nessun altro strumento
tecnologico fosse la lavatrice ha
imparato a vedere film a vedere video e
certo che c'è da ascoltare la musica e
la app è il massimo
insomma allo stato dell'arte della
fruibilità
adesso se questa tecnologia sta
arrivando anche l'accessibilità gli
speaker che mi hanno preceduto
vi hanno raccontato di un attività di
formazione attraverso la robotica mia
nipote che è il mio benchmark e
frequenta un terzo a diventare con
l'asti programmazione e quindi questa
competenza sta diventando accessibile e
la cosa interessante dello spazio cosa
che a me interessa dello spazio e che ci
costringe a progettare direttamente
nella fase up
in effetti questa che vi facciate che
adesso è una app è una app per curare le
ferite oggi la cui le ferite che chiede
le competenze specialistiche molto
avanzate per il monitoraggio anche
soltanto dell'andamento della ferita e
come funziona questa app
quello che vedete in basso è un sensore
che in grado di monitorare dei parametri
quantitativi della ferita e quindi di
comunicare anche a domenico nessuna
formazione di medicina come sta andando
la guarigione della ferita e magari cosa
deve fare come la pistola che somiglia
molto a quella di star trek e spara un
affidamento di cellule staminali
autologhe che aiuta una ricostruzione
del tessuto con questa app in teoria
anche domenico che non ha mai fatto il
medico potrebbe crearsi una ferita e
quindi cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo questa
competenza specialistica molto avanzata
l'abbiamo compressa e l'abbiamo
trasformato una tecnologia e questa
tecnologia
di fatto è utilizzabile se non da tutti
da molti questo non può che comportare
dei cambiamenti sociali non può che
mettere in condizione la società di
liberare le energie per dedicarle ad
altro e questo è uno dei motori
principali dell'evoluzione e quindi per
concludere
io non so quanto tempo ci vorrà prima
che la ricerca spaziale ci consegni
altri pianeti
so però che intanto ci sta dando subito
un'opportunità per migliorare il nostro
che mi pare occhio ne abbia bisogno
grazie
[Applauso]